السيد المتحدث أريد أن أعتذر ،
أعلم أن الملايين من الناس في
جميع أنحاء هذا البلد قد قدموا
تضحيات غير عادية
خلال الأشهر الثمانية عشر الماضية
وأنا أعلم أن الكرب الذي مروا به
غير قادرين
على الحداد على أقاربهم
غير القادرين على عيش حياتهم كما يريدون
أو القيام بذلك.  الأشياء
التي
يحبونها وأنا أعلم الغضب
الذي يشعرون
به معي
[موسيقى
] ومع الحكومة
أقودها عندما يعتقدون أنه في الشارع
نفسه ، لا يتم اتباع القواعد بشكل صحيح من
قبل الأشخاص الذين يضعون
القواعد
وعلى الرغم من أنني لا أستطيع توقع
الاستنتاجات  من الاستفسار الحالي
لقد تعلمت ما يكفي لأعرف أنه
كانت هناك أشياء
لم نحصل عليها بشكل
صحيح ويجب أن أتحمل المسؤولية
[تصفيق]
رقم 10 هو قسم كبير
به البستانيين
كامتداد للمكتب
الذي كان قيد الاستخدام المستمر لأن
لدور الهواء النقي في وقف
الفيروس وعندما ذهبت إلى تلك الحديقة
بعد السادسة في 20 مايو
2020 لأشكر مجموعات من الموظفين قبل
العودة  في مكتبي بعد 25 دقيقة
لمواصلة العمل ،
اعتقدت ضمنيًا أن هذا كان
حدث عمل
ولكن السيد المتحدث
بعد فوات الأوان كان
يجب أن
أعود للجميع في الداخل كان
يجب أن أجد طريقة
أخرى لشكرهم
وكان يجب أن أدرك أنه
حتى لو كان ذلك ممكنًا  يقال تقنيًا
بالكامل
في التوجيه ،
سيكون هناك الملايين والملايين من
الأشخاص
الذين لن يروا الأمر بهذه الطريقة ،
الأشخاص الذين عانوا بشكل رهيب
الأشخاص الذين يُحظر عليهم مقابلة
أحبائهم على الإطلاق في
الداخل أو الخارج
وإليهم وإلى هذا المنزل الذي أعرضه
اعتذاري القلبية